Hair Spray did I'll watch that once upon
a time in Hollywood worst movie I've
ever seen in my life yeah we're starting
the pod casts off like this huh not mad
that t-shirt bro that's what I'm saying
baby and buy you bill boys right there
that hit her
Aparri avon boy hopefully at this we
don't know cuz the fight is taking place
after this show hopefully you still got
that belt oh I know he got it dude and
he's all confident you're rocking the
shirt even this can be posted after the
fight that's wild huh
you were gonna buy you dumbass if he
loses there whatever boy you can't take
that gold from him bro no you can though
I've seen it man like this does he
really yeah you know I like that yeah
just like that dude I think they're
gonna have to he's gonna sneak out of
there with it I think you're right I
hope you're right
I mean look easy a look whether whoever
whatever they decided in the desert dude
you know what I'm sayin boy I know the
champions baby yeah champ gana stand
that's where they really I should be
fighting bro they could you know you
should wear more bracelets oh you look
like Criss Angel yeah whatever dude it's
Chris angle first of all guy and second
of all I'll say this dude worst movie
I've ever seen
what's poppin dolly once upon a time in
a Latino what a time yes confusing for
you yeah hard to keep up dude the
chapters are out overall I mean who
wrote the [ __ ] was
choose-your-own-adventure and somebody
else had the controls like this thing is
all a bit long
oh if you like just a long one if you
want to sleep for $22 dude go go over
there you hated it I laugh I walked out
I walked out my internet one hour and 50
minutes in what were you expecting those
just some good movie that was
understandable to people yeah that's
fair you know
and look I'm risque man I like risque
ideas you know I like puzzle tree I like
the young girls next to me fell asleep
good day yeah yeah dude this film was
putting thoughts to sleep boy what's
pretty easy to do
that's true only thoughts don't like
that movie yeah it's hard let me ask you
this though what what movies do you like
like what's your top just give me like I
hate when people go what's your favorite
movie get the [ __ ] out it like what's a
few of your time I'm saying yes it is do
what you hate what I would say is
probably a league of their own I would
say that movie where they're quite
lesbian about the water there's a
lesbians are arguing about the water you
know I'm talking about is that the help
no Mad Max no you talk about with Mel
Gibson talking about with Tom Hardy I'm
talking about Tom Hardy where that's
second one and what's the other movie I
really like Tommy Boy have you seen
Tommy Boy yep good one and probably you
know I like Bible and tape some of the
Middle Ages ratliff TBS scheduled for
Saturday leave their own Tommy Boy
spider-man one to I'm right Batman
Forever I'm reading off classics dude so
he's Russian Phi Delt this weekend
you're like mr. Rogers flavor of the
month row won't you be my flavor damn
boy you don't mean you know mr. Rogers
was a sniper
yeah dude chill [ __ ] have a lot of
them bro I'm not surprised that's why he
needed so much peace in his life yeah
that's why I dude you're trying to tone
it down and solve that war victim right
security at Harry Potter get the ride
gotta be four foot tall buddy you're
like the endemic Assessor of Quidditch
don't snitch yeah snitch buzz buzz Smith
snitch buzz - this time - this man have
a little starlet roasts my host boys
won't let them get back oh hey I'm not
mad their culture corner shirts over
there that's that hit or huh look at all
three of them on there - look at cat
looking like she looks like a character
out of um what's that game called were
your shooting people with the used cars
you know talking about uh Grand Theft
Auto yeah yeah that's it yeah telepathic
baby spiced out that culture corner
piece hell yeah I'm not mad at that at
all shout - Bryan Johnson making that
yeah dude he's great bro he designed
this he designed that man and like I
said we don't know the results of the
fight right now so um Dustin Poirier
right there gang he said right there so
you know the response that champ stamp
baby that's what you want dude again I'm
hoping he's won at this point a lot of
pressure on the young man did you see
this look even if he like Abby Bharath
for a little bit bro he'll [ __ ] have
that [ __ ] back yeah Pam hey don't it's
a one shot for him and I hope it works
out being real but what he beats him
he's getting Conor McGregor then he's
making real cheddar
Kabhi bro i'll just telling you this
dude that man got could beat in the
desert right right again i hope you're
watching this
to beat yeah Kabhi ting good
then you walk around and kajak the stand
okay i'ma get raped dude I can't believe
ya brah I mean I can't even you know
women can't even touch themselves over
there or anything for money or what
makes a lot of sense though let's kick
this off just ready yeah get me out of
this conversation with Brandon how about
this from Miguel Rojo Brennen looks like
a go-kart mechanic one piece that one zu
in that little hi girls Theo looks like
he drives swamp boats for over Brendon
probably lives in a gated community
this is on gay you open the gate a jog
looks like he sells glow sticks at
Juggalo festivals do you wanna [ __ ] and
enjoy the experience are you gonna see
your weed this will make me laugh so
hard
Brandon looks like the type that will
end up in area 52 during the 51 recall
chin man is everybody Theo von looks
like he was drawn up by Mike judge we do
look like beavers about head
Brendan looks like a buff pigeon pigeon
boy that's what I'm talking about bro do
a pigeon bro that's the deets uh this is
the fillet of Detroit bro bro the
Cyclopes dude those last two were
hitters Theo was the kind of guy that
sneakers pay raccoon into a yellow of
concert you know looks like he sells
bananas at a Grateful Dead shots last
one
Brendan is the final boss you have to
beat at a cologne kiosk in the mall
[Laughter]
[Music]
King Koopa King Koopa that Buckingham
mall that estee lauder Bowser brother
you that Christian Dior dragons wawas
battles are my Johnny Depp time to pay
the bills
dude I gotta ask you man cuz I know that
your business man yes you know and I
know that you also watch a lot of Tel
Aviv
how much time do you spend in front of
the computer screen in digital screens
overall to 23 hours a day
jeepers man yeah my eyes are hurting
yeah between your phone work watching
new shows watching this show video games
scrolling YouTube the YouTube all I do
is watch canvas stay yeah well that's
why I started wearing MVM tees ever
scroll blue light filtering glasses what
yeah man you know it they're built to
protect your eyes from blue light that's
known to cause eye strain discomfort
poor sleeping patterns - does it sharpen
in my vision and improve focus and
mental clarity this is nuts
yep it's nuts all right dude wow man
it's exactly what you said it does
elevates mood lowers stress hormones man
you all stressed out no joke because
you've been trying to read off of a
little bitty phone you friggin
delinquent dude here's my thing though I
gotta look cool I want to look cool or
they stylish or do I look I look like an
old school freakin dork I mean look cool
dude do they have cool stylish glasses
if you look I have no idea what your
definition of cool is bro no one just
saying do they have cool yes they got
cool what do you think is just you just
hold two pieces of glass in front of
your face yeah I did
I thought the table another they look
just like regular glasses there's no
yellow tint lenses like you find on blue
blockers or blue blue [ __ ] or any of
that I can pick from round clear or
colored frames this is nuts
it's snazzy baby it's MVM tees selection
it's always expanding and they always
have the snazziest stuff man better
focus better sleep better style get 15
sent off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to nvm t.com slash
cats shop movement right now protect
your eyes and look great doing it go to
em be empty comm slash cats yep blue
light filtering glasses MVM t.com / k
80s it's a commercial from King in the
state man to put a lot of money on my
boy last week dude good for you man
sometimes you win them sometimes you
lose them you know yep but the point is
there's big fights come up there's big
football games coming up and you want to
make Bank and I'm telling about my
bookie it's fast it's easy they pay when
you win let's face it where you're
betting is just as important as who
you're betting on some people don't
follow through my bookie they follow
through
yup some people can't read him right
dude look I wouldn't be telling you guys
to bet if you didn't want to okay I'm
not saying bad everything you got your
family can't eat I'm saying make some
choice bets and when you do bet at my
bookie dot-com nothing makes the game
more fun when you're buck buckaroos on
the line join now and my bookie will
double your first deposit use promo code
cats to activate the offer that's promo
code cat's visit my bookie dot a G today
you play you win you get paid wrong yeah
man do a couple of things I bet the
under on wins for Tampa Bay that's
something I'm going at this year I liked
it over for the Browns yeah I like all
pounds I could see that the over for the
Browns and I also think that the bangles
are gonna do better than people expect
them so there's a couple of my ideas
right there but you can visit my bookie
dot AG today support the podcast let me
tell you this I've been wearing other
Underpants and I have now changed these
things you have to call them Underpants
like you're my dad you just say
underwear I could call a mantis that's
what a lot of guys oh dude alright
what's your favorite man tease do these
things it's almost like having a strong
guy just hold onto your waist and junk
and butt man but I'm talking about that
Mack Weldon it's better than whatever
you're wearing right now they're more
for that machismo you know if you want
to look premium already you want to look
like you know you might throw a rock
somebody ordered a soup bro yeah it's
more that chunky soup right you don't
want you're not coming with that small
salmon you coming with that with that
real freaking the drought hitter that
real solid frickin body mahi-mahi
yeah Matt gralton will be the most
comfortable underwear socks shirt under
church hoodies and sweatpants that you
will ever wear and they got a lot of
silver underwear and shirts that are
naturally antimicrobial interesting yeah
put on the noose pronouncing it yeah so
now it's back Wilkins underwear socks
t-shirts look good they prefer or I'm so
well dude oh they are they just snuggle
up next to you dude like god we love her
we just love who you just met him
outside of a mall man these things will
just hug right onto your body like a
best friend that never gonna go anywhere
to change them yeah I got two pairs on
Underpants right now from Neymar
beautiful unders and yeah they sent me a
pair of underwear and I just I've
refused to take him off
oh I refuse to take them off 79 those
are the mic Rio b-17 days Mac Mac life
baby yeah gift 20% for first order visit
Mac well ENCOM enter promo code cats
that's right and they have a guarantee
as well so if you don't like your first
pair you can keep it and I will still
refund you know you can ask me a bunch
of questions though no questions asked
keep your sack well in these Mac
Wheldon's you got me there and then we
have them streaks anymore
again for 20% off your first order visit
Mac Weldon wel do in comm and enter
promo code k a TS mac I need more undies
knock knock who's there
Pacey old Brendan with a little debate
club that's great dude have funnier
people man God people are [ __ ] this
one over Boober hilarious sorry I'm late
Gators bags
go ahead good game sorry I'm late you
know water's rising
sighs watching does importance track of
time
shop party oh [ __ ] first we got a Matt
from Cincinnati this is Matt from synthy
what's up Taylor what's up Brandon got a
debate club here for you I was wondering
when you go out to the bars or clubs you
try and pick up on random chicks and
take them home or do you go with girls
that are your friends or maybe
acquaintance is a friends and you know
get a couple drinks in you and see where
the night goes ding-a-ling clog butt
plugs you I'm ding-a-ling yeah you
definitely Daniel it yeah you like
tingling he definitely blood all right
Dingling what'd he say I mean wars
options to how to meet women why don't
you meet randomly go and hoping you're
gonna like buy some leave some drink
less roar rape ISM that's not racism
what sauce called The Cosby play it's
tough yeah it's tough playing the old
cause beginning or you're friends with
her already or you know you knew or
somehow maybe already met somewhere yeah
it's better to kind of have some sort of
starting relationship some sort of jump
you know a little LeapPad phrase just
wandering to the night help me get a
nice young lady yeah so girls are also
going out from one reason to that dick
let's be real are they yeah you think
they're they're just a dance with their
friends that they've known for years and
circles and get hammered
ya know hoping they get plucked out by a
nice gentleman with a big dick what yeah
that's why they're out who's looking cat
agreed with me she I thought girls of us
out to have a good time also are the
guys with chicks I mean you're both but
do you think like at the end of the
night girls are open the guys try to
pick them up or no yeah if they're
single fits of five single girls you
think they're going out like [ __ ]
he-man woman haters Club like when
[ __ ] when I got to look all scared at
the end of the night kind of
cuz your haircut but in general it's
pretty easy yeah that's true maybe I
should get a different style mm-hmm
yeah or just go earlier and just yeah
let him know at least I'm gonna look
like this later as well yeah I think
people got a twist they think girls is
going out to dance the night away that's
what I thought
I was gonna get some dick well I should
put a sign up that says that thing
because people have no idea I think what
I do on Instagram it's like a bad signal
y'all get their Instagram yeah thoughts
on there bro get a couple drinks go with
your buddies yeah walk up what's up
[ __ ] damn were you meeting girls at
dude I haven't been that's frowned upon
so don't take advice from where you mean
girls in 1800s girl that [ __ ] Sigma
Pi alpha you look like you're us for
more pie pie like a thick fella put some
desserts dude dude you a sorority chick
you're the best
pehle fighter the sorority testosterone
it's not fair yeah they're just
injections I'll be fine TIFF also get
you take out of our face it's a long
vagina I think you should go the club
meet some girls I think that's an insane
idea I think meet girls and in vitamist
see you somewhere and then hang out at
my chill environment I think the real
best way to meet women a lot of people
analyze is just to invite people out as
groups of just fun people don't make it
pressure some and just try to have fun
and then then see if something escalates
because otherwise you just stand where
answer yes trying to stare at somebody
so hard across the room they know you
want to [ __ ] nuts and
I swear to say but I'll then but then
you're trying to look like a fun time so
you're drinking your hand you're kind of
doing this and then when you're drunk
it's even more creepy and then you get
the balls to go over the nights so late
yeah yeah I am I am
that's the worst row yeah are you
waiting for them like bill the baths
like what are you doing here taking a
[ __ ] bro
I've seen that thousand times who do you
mean I haven't found the hot snot listen
to me and it's really hot here I'm
getting dehydrated is this hot in here
this [ __ ] this Harry Potter Gucci
shoes
calm down I can't make the white guy in
that Fresh Prince of bel-air episode
where they get busted for drugs at
school oh cool haven't seen it someone
look that up so we get the joke what
else you got man
seventy percent will with girls you know
yeah people a bunch of [ __ ] you just
gonna shoot your shot man oh yes nice
bird there you somethin BTK right now a
sniper these [ __ ] are human beings
bro these [ __ ] are human beings
dude send them a wheel of cheese send
these hoes some cheese chin style a nice
sharp cheddar and a DM goes a long ways
these days what else you got dude this
is from Derrick Bush gee how'd you put
how'd you pick up your girl what was she
doing she go hot top running trying to
get into her car did you sound any more
like every woman that's ever been
kidnapped what happened I thought he had
a perfect smush she was walking down the
stairs I was like damn you got a perfect
smile girl she was like that's all it
took this see that's how easy it is now
imagine if she was drunk talk all USA's
yeah both eyes yeah when they're drunk
it's so easy
damn you breathe in this oxygen
crazy girl damn girl you got teeth yeah
you're nuts
I know dude look at Derek picking up
girls off elevators come on going
hey cool lips know she know you got a
girl in this [ __ ] house cleaning you
want to go down that's what you say to
him well I got creepy damn it you're
going down cuz I'm rising huh huh that's
you [ __ ] dude nothing just what are
you gonna leave me hangin bro at the
[ __ ] last straw nope
you [ __ ] Double Down yes we got a double
down his loss from another Derek before
you play us cat where'd you meet your
man did you I'd feel like you picked him
up I met him in high school he was a
breakdancer he was breaking breakdancing
in the middle of the quad he like did
air flare and looked at his game overs
Wow and did you say you're going coming
with me yes
yeah I feel like you're the Derek in the
relationship you pop locked his way into
my life
yeah that's Jerry one day we'll ask you
one day we'll ask you yeah go ahead
she was about to jump on the mic to well
for me yeah well we're good we're good
you still single out there Chan or not
okay and what kind of girls do you like
just so some of the ladies are listening
to know you like to count five girls
what what I don't like aggressive girls
you know like I even talked to you about
this field and the DMS when they're too
aggressive and they show tits and ass
right away yeah that stuff's nasty if it
was just like hey on well-lit jpig of a
[ __ ] quarter of at it dude nothing
will put me to sleep quicker than that
God buncha [ __ ] sayonara bro that's
my [ __ ] you you what do you mean quit
what are you looking for Chan you
looking for like a southern belle who's
like Simon back here on the cheek for
six weeks a southern belle and northern
tambourine he'll take a beautiful
instrument of the Lord yeah
dorky mmm goofy cute all right I like it
what else you guys thanks guys don't
thank me
my man Brennan James Shaw my big boy
Derek and my girl Kat I got a question
for you guys
debate club IPAs this is Donna
background or are y'all about them cheap
beers to [ __ ] chug no get that Miller
Lite hitter that that was walking look
at these boys from them with the Burke
baby club love me here boys
first of all shots a bishop gun playing
in the background they're beautiful shut
up - these two young men having a nice
bubbly you know I'm saying oh yeah a
couple guys in a basement drinking -
this is Midwest life this is America
mystery this is so goddamn American
goddamn did I salute this [ __ ] can Oh
Brava mile-high salute to you [ __ ]
I'll attack these guys for oil bro it's
how [ __ ] American I am huh I'll dig
up in their backyard brother bombs yeah
mines and [ __ ] praise God brother I'd
like to say this I like a I like a real
shitty beer man if I'm gonna have a beer
dude I like to alright I don't mind if
half of his spills down my [ __ ] shirt
you know drowns my cat whatever dude I
don't give a damn bro now I'll put a
little in my fish tank matter of fact
yeah something you can [ __ ] you know
split with your fish
yeah something you could [ __ ] kind of
spice up that flounder by the
old-fashion yeah that Miller High Life
for that [ __ ] scorpion you feel me
yeah a little Miller High Life for your
[ __ ] clown fish it's easy for two
betta fish to fightin Bravo watch them
fight in a [ __ ] little love when you
put a little bit of gin between them
yeah a little Mickey's in that yeah see
what happens they get scrappier oh I
like a nice IPA listen I like both of
them I like a nice hoppy IPA I like a
local beer you know I'm saying I like a
nice hoppy local beer whatever city I'm
in can't have beer right now cuz I'm the
kedo kid yeah so are you the kid Oh kid
yeah I'm down 16 pounds bro really yeah
lots I started heavy that's very easy
yeah thanks man you seem like the Chito
kid because ya Sager oh well I'm not
you look great manners what I'm trying
to tell you but what this guy is saying
yeah man I think if you're hanging out
with the you get those hoppy beers man
it just tastes all you know reminds me
of my past too much start tape drinking
and tasting around you of like you know
going a wood shop and yeah yeah being in
violence domestic disputes it's your own
demons in the closet don't hate on all
IPA cuz you grew up weird you know I'm
saying
what a nice hoppy beers out there but I
like that [ __ ] Miller lying board bro
the kind of [ __ ] that makes you think
you know I'm not getting a damn car
accident tonight yeah that Coors Light
hitter oh yeah all down 12 of those
inside is it Aquafina
or is it beer makes you know I'm
hammered can't see behind the wheel time
yeah it's a fun time I wish the cops had
to guess what you've been drinking in
order to actually give you a DUI yeah
that's a good idea it would be good huh
cuz I like to mix it up I put a piece of
bubblegum up in my mouth good luck boys
really yeah if you put like six or seven
pennies in your mouth I can't tell that
you've been drinking they can tell
however you've been hiding pennies in
your mouth that the detectives will
figure out they have seven cents in
you're out they have any for your
thoughts what do we got 58 58 percent
cheap beer yeah it's just a good time
they're played Edward forty hands yeah
they're played that game yeah well I
thought it was like a special thing with
me and my friends only it's not it's a
pretty common game extremely popular Wow
yeah you take to forties chin doesn't
know what it is you take two forties you
duct tape around your two hands you
can't put them down to finish drinking
them mm-hmm yeah hammered yeah I almost
died myself yet people die every year
doing that and what I'm talking about is
that sometime we used to play yeah we'd
wear raincoats and [ __ ] put on listen
to some juvenile and get all [ __ ] up
mmm why the raincoats though I don't
know you're a fan of the Columbine kids
or what just young no not uh you're
talking about Wyatt Earp kind of jacket
sometime a raincoats
all right the yellow one yeah oh all
right just in case yeah we can we can
make
do juvenile did it bro oh he got busted
in a neighborhood next of ours he chased
a woman with a ice pick down the street
oh why cuz you're stealing his beef I
don't know what happened he's got it
just domestic dispute see a live dog a
still-life is he still making jams
what do deliveries for what but his main
jams were back there that girl good
won't you back that song called ha - he
had the hot boys the hot boy did you HOT
or get a bunch it's a thing
yeah good runner with little Wayne was
with him too hot boys he's a wine yeah
he was like 9 rapping with [ __ ]
juvenile yeah man and BG got on the
drugs that thank you
what would you have had oh he's that you
want you're fine I love talking about
you back that up but he had one more
that we he had one more that will slap
your nuts dude
Big Tymers he was in big towns to some
terms of huh why they get a mug shot
from my man all the pictures you know
any pictures the Isles online you gotta
use a mug shoppers we compete if I can
hang eaters but I think I get a couple
of me so emotion for me slow most
involvement do you remember that one she
were connect back I don't know how to X
no motive okay hit it
that's a comment is genius that's good
let's get our it hell yeah
they played this in my grandmother's
funeral damn
makes you want to hit somebody
this is number one this is about being a
chiropractor most of it her neck and her
back hurting fast god damned it boy what
else they got hello sorry gonna take
this call the cake did calls from
friends than a Miller our show yeah yeah
it was for my fresh sambar he left it
for me and he's come back to get it huh
Oh
rodeo thank you so much gonna go I need
a hot or thank you guys so much
alright praise God who made that rodeo a
member last one then we'll move on hit
me that rodeo you remember this one deal
oh dude
Oh rody yo Oh
rody yo ah oh my god bro this is getting
disgusting dude about the bus tonight
politicians they got he had the heads
thanks for thanks for bringing those
memories back dude that dude he had a
budget I'm sorry this relationship
advice no I'm gonna shine my ride boys
yeah but I think you should take the
girl out man I wouldn't just meet her at
a bar dude you know cheap beer that's
right no you know get a girl in by
Archie beer let's combine the two get a
girl Edward forty hands if I'm drinking
during the day Coors Light if I'm
drinking on the river first bag on the
river in your water good right dude
Coors Light Colorado's finest biz just
something about it has so much water in
it
all right in with the waters cold it's
that Colorado River cold water risk and
you don't even care if you lose a can of
it like who gives us four years yeah you
could get mortgage hope drink some of
the river you probably get half you know
you get a little bit of a hit god it's
nice time to buy fuel more pants this is
it baby
what dude well it's time man this is it
it's time to announce the wicks
competition winner dude if I think it is
iron gold knives from Canada that's it
oh my god the handcrafted culinary
knives made in Nova Scotia oh that's
cool and fortune to high carbon steel we
reviewed the submissions and man this
one was a lat trash yeah this was
perfect here if you even look at his
site in the upper right corner they have
a quick link to the Etsy shop you get to
see the different styles of knives that
he has and even here we if you look you
could see Jeremy's home base and the
photos and and everything that he does
in his shop man Wow four to six weeks to
make one of these knives right yeah
that's way too long
scrolling down the page chappy features
the quality Knight yeah they do this
ain't no butter knife baby these aren't
cheap butter knives that we're talking
about here each one takes forever like
you said man that's crazy oh well look
before I saw this site man I'd never
even considered buying like a real
traditional Japanese vegetable knife but
now I did I was about to buy one where
are you I was about to buy a Japanese
vegetable knife the traditional type and
I'm like you know what
wow great work on the knives Jeremy and
great work on the Wix homepage
submission mmm well Jeremy wanted Jeremy
the champ champ champ champ champ status
Congrats Jeremy good luck with your
knives man you've won the grand prize
it's $400 value of a Wix homepage for a
year that's yours and you know what I'm
gonna get one or Jimmy's knives I am too
also I want you guys know it was a very
tough competition and shout-out to
Jeremy yeah there was some real that
coffin guy the guy doing the coffins who
else knows a little about the cheddar
guy because I make the delicious cheddar
you had the only cheese that exists
what about the guy making rabbit feet
called Lucky's dude that Agha grew up
with they used to sell raccoon erection
or wiener necklace yeah I'd buy that I'd
buy that mm-hmm and it was Nate it was
something for Native America Congrats
Jimmy Congrats Jeremy you've won the
grand prize brother [ __ ] dude hit my
[ __ ] elbow on this [ __ ] dude
yeah bro Congrats bro someone's got to
pay for Brendan's coffee habit let me
say this man I've had hair issues my
entire life dude right now I got so much
hair on my butt and I wish I had a
little bit more on my head you do you
wish it was a little thicker up top yeah
you know nice Philly fade on your ball
sack yeah I want them it's hairy down
there bro thicker on my ticker man yeah
get that jheri curl on your [ __ ]
listen 66% of men start to lose their
hair by h35 avro and once you notice it
way too late yup you got to catch that
hair at the pass boy you better get that
hair before you end up without hair to
that hairline slowly starting to fade
back cuz father times your barber I
don't let him control the way you look
man just over here for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for the borough's do
keep your brain right keep your hair
right keep your Weiner right bro
everything for hims dot-com /k 80s order
now and our listeners gifts get started
with the hems complete hair kit they got
it all man also they get them dick pills
for you no more awkward in-person doctor
visits come straight to your door it's
discreet yeah so dang easy stop waiting
start getting your dick and your hair
browner up dog yeah bro good of for hims
calm slash cats that's fo rh IMS calm
slash cats for hims dot-com slash cats
yeah get your boner C website for full
details and safety information this
could cost hundreds if you went to the
doctor or pharmacy or somewhere else get
that cheap wiener baby for hims calm / k
80s
best
you're dead trying to keep the lights on
what else we got let's try my rise up
first this is Brent Cormier and we've
seen a car like this before what the
[ __ ] is going on with these cars man
dude if the second or the country are
they you sorta oh that's Florida boy
David it's that big screen on the side
there though watch a nice football game
bet you watch the Gators on the side
hurricane bro if I freakin if I hurt if
a storm picks this thing up it'll be
fine bro just fine this that hurricane
look at that TV on the outside bro
microwave on the outside
oh this that this that party Cruiser you
want that hot pocket dude that Gator
Cruiser put your toe strudel up in there
Wow look it is the Lord's emblem on top
the Lord's logo Jesus Jesus shield as we
call Yale baby
praise Allah and look at that door too
with the window on the door again might
be repetitive but I got asked where does
that door lead to the inside of the
truck dude I does it sound like very
like it's him work it you know I'm
saying right he's just there you don't
know how to live you rich [ __ ]
brah look at this oh no the old one that
was the one from before just to compare
see yeah that one's scarier with the
clown one yeah the red door scary this
one it looks like this edge is trying to
party get to the game Florida Florida
State you know I'm saying
Florida State Penitentiary dude this guy
looks like he's raising chickens nude
and this has a nice door on the side of
his van okay you ain't lying that might
be that Ted Bundy hit her a chicken coop
Deville bro that thing has [ __ ] I
think it has netting and stuff on the
side of it
it's very strange man bro it's just a
JPEG and it smells like chicken feed
that's how severe looking it is it is
ply wood walls bro it looks like his
dream was to have this car when he was a
kid and just never gave up the dream
yeah yeah dude if I went up the end with
a door and a TV and a microwave this mom
was like okay good luck in any pain
lawyers later
any kind of moms heads off took her
[ __ ] cash and there you go this thing
makes my bowels hurt bro looking at it
me to get this [ __ ] on my face
yeah that car Gators though that van
gives me driver Rio bro next we got Alan
pelegrin jr. oh he's from the south -
where's he from Alan pelegrin mm-hmm
he's got that Dale Earnhardt jr. car
gang [ __ ] with eyebrows on the front oh
yeah oh that's that Hitler I saw you put
the three that's anthony drive this bro
look at those eyebrows on the front of
that car
oh wow there's a really good playing
Words I thought but no I dug your dude
I dug it you dropping heat today man and
look at that oh I love it when somebody
takes a shitty car and puts the number
three that Dale Earnhardt on the side or
is a Tony Stewart who's that no that's
Dale Earnhardt yes let me tell you
something you're disrespecting Dale
Earnhardt when you do this [ __ ] you know
I'm saying he doesn't want this you
don't like this clean your ride up then
put the three on there think wants to be
on a Saturn with a blown-out ass in the
back what happened in a trailer come on
dude I like the bullet holes in the back
of the Saturn bro because here's the
thing man you got a shoot for the moon
dude that's what life's all about
and sometimes you hit Saturday you gotta
shoot for the moon and look right you
put a trailer hitch on a Saturn dude
that tells a lady look I'm gonna own
something one day okay
it also says I might have this shitty
hoopty but we can go wherever we want
yeah we might live in Arkansas now but
let's drive down to Florida beachfront
property yeah the world's yours girl
yeah Easter the world is your oyster and
uh indefinitely the car with the
eyebrows on the front dude [ __ ] all of
that let's talk to our agent corner over
here because I know that you guys
specialize in eyebrows in eyes brows
wait do they do it
I didn't know about this I think so you
guys do a lot of it you know unique kind
of like hair on the car let's do
something crazy you know we do jump out
crisis if I say yeah mmm they don't put
eyebrows on cars what do they do they
very white southern thing I see is it
yeah Asians don't want it that's mm-hmm
no we kind of add we add spoilers on
things no but a spoiler on a Buick that
makes sense and what else what are some
other accoutrement you might see in a in
an Eastern vehicle on an Eastern vehicle
there will
be eyelashes inside of the car region
girls will always take off their fake
eyelashes leave them somewhere and then
just find like random eyelashes
everywhere and you'll mistake them for
our spider
I call them caterpillars yeah that's hot
though Wow
it's only hot when you have them on it's
always hot
no I dig it I know she's a downer yeah
and go seek Brodus your frickin IP she's
about to do some work
does it really I don't know what kind of
work looks like she's not gonna go to
work yeah or she is about to go to work
you can feel me do but some nuts now Jim
with something unique you'll put into
your vehicle do it I know you definitely
have things that you'd like to think
about inside or on the outside I guess
he's off uh side markers then what do
you mean by that like a little blinking
lights on the side of your door that was
popular in the car racing Oh like the
defender fender yeah yeah okay and now
an Asian person that cannot race cars
you guys look down upon within the
community well they never had a good
like Indy racer yeah I mean we only do
street racing yeah they specialize in
drifting gifting breakdancing no turns
bro no turns of Eagles Asian people are
not good in uh they're great when they
are in one place you get an Asian
emotion
Iwo Jima bro great great job defending
Iwo Jima right in one place pro kamikaze
in the plane you put an Asian in a plane
crashing crashing into other people -
these are points you people in motion
it's just some people have certain
skills and bam it's not I think that
facts Asians are more of you set a
nation somewhere anything is possible
dude but you start moving them around
put them on rollerskates dude
go behind the wheel oh yeah anything is
you know and not every night soon now
they're mine
alright but I think you know everybody
on your downs they do everyone has their
flaws Ben what's not flaws I wouldn't
say I'd say release may be a flaw you
can't work when you move yeah you're
right what else we got how about a
little relationship advice boys yeah
you're helping people one relationship
at a time man okay fine Derek will do
everything you want to do Derek
alright this is Nick from Boston sup
deal
so Brandon names Nick from Boston needs
some relationship advice right so I got
this done I just might even be a 12 out
of 10 but yeah bro but the commitment
type person right now no no she is
either a thing right now you're not got
us together like I said she's smoking so
uh I killed I know what you guys think
I'm 25 kind of at that point where like
I could sell it down but I know if I
want to you know how it is
so yeah it rolled on 39 and I'm at that
point wise for wisdom masters over there
Oh him Brendan's never been here call
man you just saw me tear up a little
when he smile and some dark times and I
appreciate that gangbang
I love this guy oh you be my friend I
love him I think I'm bossy in January
brother we gotta meet up free tickets on
me but bring your dime even if it's not
with ya um man twenties 25 she's a nurse
she's 25 but is she 25 he didn't say
what she was but she's a nurse isn't
hers and she's a dime get up brother
a 12 I'll be the judge of that but a 12
and she's a nurse that mean she takes
care of people yeah she sounds nice bro
sounds pretty cool and even if you're
not ready to lock it down right now
at least uh you know at least start
fabricating the key I think a little bit
you know you could start to think you
know at least treat her well so you got
an opportunity down the line with here's
the thing though down the line fish like
that they get picked up real quick she's
gonna be ready down the line yeah I'm
saying have you know a shitty and she's
at twelve everywhere she goes every
dudes trying to [ __ ] her
so eventually some dudes are Jordan they
are what they are
chin see thanks for uh here's a pussy's
boy here dude walk it up it's what she's
a twelve urinating someone's gonna lock
it up or you know what don't listen the
guy who's married with two kids listen
to the single guy and this crazy ass
yeah what is my case
arrest my kids yeah what'd you - what
was your case dude - lock it up okay
or it was don't lock no I said to lock
it up my whole thing I'm saying lock it
up here's what I'm saying down the line
it could happen make sure you've stained
a good contact that jingoes I agree
don't listen to them they're all singles
[ __ ] well look I'll tell you this
Randall what's his name Nick Nick dude
yeah rant Nick I usually I grew up with
a kid named Nicholas Randle actually
ended up being honestly homosexual but
I'll say this to your brother is that
yeah if you think she's the one but you
said she's still running around so
unless you could put that squeeze in her
you know unless you get that inner
little baby bear and hit her up with
that gasm and get you a baby then you
might have a tough time one way to lock
down a real hot chick is to get her
pregnant you know you could do that man
that's an old school move bro it's a few
things you're hot
yeah well here have a baby but then nine
months she's back to being real hot
yeah but she's got an H it's just H own
outside h.o.t yeah you right
you know you meet ho I just mean it's
like you know it's just yeah there's
some more priorities out every night you
can't always put a B yeah you can't put
that little uh you know you can't so no
chill anymore
yeah and that's Netflix and children
good luck good keep touching me though
high your button doesn't work bro ah
[ __ ]
yeah all right we'll fly my out boys
yeah a couple on oh I'm for first we got
up Holly Drew's this is on Holly great
name oh is it the famous Oh mm-hmm
[Music]
mm-hmm she's a nanny uh and she's 23
years old she looks definitely very
beautiful for like Davie crackhead bro
she's definitely different beer bongs
you know wearing a Coonskin cap and
that's the only reason I said that but
outside of that I love the fact she's
obviously an animal lover she likes the
outdoors even though she's indoors she
has on welding glasses Davy Crockett got
some tits the other thing is yet you
know way to maybe jeweled jeans girl you
know I'm saying yeah I'm not sure Criss
Angel II can't be wearing those just
like wear them you like the True
Religion vibe I'll make those things
disappear daddy your halo me breath you
mean just take them off oh yeah Brian
okay
yeah like the Davy Crockett hat though
that that's probably the best part of
this whole thing yeah and this is also a
lot of these those uh Coonskin caps are
sold for rabies awareness and so I love
anybody's doing that cuz we lose almost
60 people every year to rabies I'm not
mad at the Bret Hart sunglasses either
mm-hmm those go hard in the paint
what's her special technique she in deep
throat yeah oh my god understand why
she's chugging the bear bro I don't know
what's going on there I know you know
[Laughter]
well she has a medium like the arms and
she's trying to do a beer bong don't do
it have someone else hold it for you
correct you have no friends I have
medium length arms and we don't beer
bong okay
you just keep the limited actions
handshake
you know maybe light hand signals when
you're turning on a bicycle but nothing
[ __ ] crazy just crazy flows you don't
hug from far away extended her elbow is
yeah it's a real strain very Kurt Cobain
yeah very Kurt Cobain although he did it
down she's doing it up what else we got
shout out to that aunt though man good
luck with your relationship this is aunt
Roger
damn Roger
whoa goddamn Raza now the way she the
hunter percent Native American and she
approved these photos for you boys
damn who sent them in this little Navajo
hitter
this ain't no more Raja it's a real
brother
then tits are real once your seminal
into my pants oh my god you're talking
about I'm just saying I got a teepee
down there are you really you're
disgusting don't get erected working
good I'll tell you this she's obviously
she travels a lot there's different
backgrounds in the two photos she's by a
fireplace right there now she likes
Christmas but also a masquerade party so
it looks like maybe it's a little Mardi
Gras Christmastime I don't if you mix
those two dude I'll freakin put some
sandwich meat on those tits and go get a
little ham demonium going on do me
breasting whatever dude I'm sorry I
don't think you're discussing I was
thinking the exact same thing on
Apocalypto those tits
Apocalypto it was the killing of a lot
of Native American Sylvan too bro okay
my bad man oh man I'm being really a
naysayer God dang man
mmm yeah what's her problem is her uncle
won't leave her alone what was the
problem she lost one of her wolves I'll
tell you we could dancing with the walls
with her dude you feel me
hmm I would definitely take a sip off of
that water flaunting I'll definitely be
your last of the Mohicans go yeah let's
move on we've done enough she's a native
Indian references you know I'm saying oh
yeah man
Geronimo these nuts my god your 4-year
old you're like a four year old dude Oh
all right boys let's wrap it up okay
interesting it and that'll be it
first we got Chris Sanders this is Chris
oh it better be it because I get this
sweat suit hot and I am NOT doing well
see Santa's boy Colonel Sanders dude
great beard Sofia burnin and it's Chris
Florida I came here stinking for you
guys today your door-knocking
gang gang buzz buzz what is he called
door-to-door sales
door knocking dude I know about that you
did I used to do I sell supplements and
do that and it's the worst job in the
world
you went door to door to door before I
get to the UFC anything surprised you
didn't get murdered from me to row me to
some dicey situation walk around Denver
selling supplements door-to-door there's
the worst job I've ever had
it's very dangerous also everyone hates
you yeah cuz they're like why they like
I have this creatine for a limited time
here's the toughest job in the world
also sting it it's not gonna work dude
there's Amazon I can order where the
[ __ ] light comes that day I respect
it man I say you King that man it's a
hustle but also pursuit of happiness
already happen no they used to have a
man would come bust and sell dish soap
dude and he couldn't even talk bro and
he would just show you the soap and for
a long time and keep showing it to you
and you'd have to buy it and it was only
most effective sales techniques I've
ever seen dude silence soap sales
interesting yeah maybe I'll tell you
this somebody [ __ ] beats a big box of
soap against your [ __ ] door for ten
minutes you buying it you'll give that
dude $12 to [ __ ] walk away here's the
only door-to-door sales that works these
days and they can't go door-to-door
anymore because one of them was more
but one of the Girl Scout cookies I buy
a shitload those cookies you make it
easy on me oh man did amazon ain't scale
Girl Scout cookies so joke's on you mr.
Bezos well I'll lick the cinnamon off a
[ __ ] Asian girls back bro for a
couple of dollars you know especially if
they going door-to-door so definitely I
think that door sales are good what I
don't like is the people your magazines
all these [ __ ] coming by hey do
you want this subscription to outdoor
life you know do you want this
subscription to outdoor life dude
they're not around anymore so I'm giving
the money and you never get any money
anymore you're not around anymore dude
you know what people you know the door
to door now have you seen the family's
like oh we're trying to pay for the
funeral and they're trying to collect
cash that's all a hustle you know that
yeah and they know white people doing
those Hmong people right those are your
people I don't want to say anything to
the culture corner hope you say some is
that of a black door-to-door activity we
do that man we love to sell you know
like promote our peewee football team
different jerseys on it's like what team
is it dude how about that [ __ ] in
front of every Ralph's with the Bell
Gandhi that's Santa is it well Santa's
asked me for money
yeah dude cuz people are dying bro it's
called Salvation Army you might be right
well I'll tell you what drives by
Tagalongs from them yeah well I'll tell
you this dude is that knife sales now
it's more of a white people think people
going door to door selling knives knives
yeah and dude and it works like can I
see you know hey can I see a piece of
wood yeah yeah I guess I'm a piece of
wood they take it out and just chomp
dude I'm like that's pretty cool man
they give me every time they used to
have his do called the Swans Gotham
account door-to-door remember him and
bro he just pulled up and he had a huge
freezer he was driving basically a huge
freezer and be like you want cookies you
want steaks but we want it oh yeah I
remember charged up $3 with a [ __ ] deal
where your parents were going they were
like kids it's by [ __ ] and there's some
good t-bones though the batter oh so
good everything tasted the same no
matter what it was
have you ever thought the guy were you
here somewhere and he's like yo you want
TV man or they have like TVs VCRs back
and a flat screens demahjay players yeah
used to be sometimes you would buy the
box and then there was nothing in the
box it was like weighted or something
you know I never happened to me well but
I don't like that yeah everybody used to
do Cutco knives and all of that I'd
rather sell drugs I think me too way
easier also that's not door to door
though doridori is it's humiliating man
that's what it's not though it's worse
job I love it when they come by and
you're a kid you like who's here you
know yeah it might be fun when you're
the kid but when you're the man selling
it trying to make ends meet it's a tough
gig dude and kids are dumb to you'll be
like it like someone's airing like hey
your parents help me like nope there
will be a parade then you get [ __ ]
molested kids we can't button all these
are bad dude next we got Scott Davis
this is Scott coming to you from the
cowboy state the big beautiful state of
Wyoming and man [ __ ] well okay anyway
trade Jeff Brandon I'm not too far from
where you were you from in Aurora I got
family living arrived but that's besides
the point I gotta dodge bullets bro you
guys here's a little background I work
full-time my wife works full-time and we
got two beautiful little bread Snatchers
don't make it to the gym as often as I
would like and I got that dad Bach
coming in bro and I'm not proud of it
but it's coming in sproutin the hopper
button oh yeah that's what I got king of
sting it dad buds dude love you dude
shout out to Wyoming my neighbors I love
Wyoming man I've been to Cheyenne before
watched a guy get hit by actually know
what I watched I got jump out of a hotel
room and die
commit suicide they say and uh X was in
Montana was he doing all completely
different every moment she doing for
good cause though why was he doing no I
think freedom I was on doing drugs
during the day I let it do it I hate
being on drugs during the day dude why
would you do it during the day
wait
nightfall yeah that's when Satan comes
out um dad buzz the hopper Bob dude I
feel like that was the hopper bod it
didn't I didn't realize it don't want to
catch with my kid I looked at all the
other dad's there shred city sometimes
life you just wake up one more you're
273 pounds you have no idea what
happened it's the way it works it's kind
of cool though
but there's difference now hear me out
there there's a difference between dad
hopper Bob and there's just straight-up
fat don't be trying to say oh I get
deference I had a friend of mine yeah
when you just fat you're fat don't call
a dad bod cuz there's just fat you know
I'm saying oh yeah man I know him please
bro it's all about it's all about your
diet though bro
yeah dude first of all the guys two kids
he's doing the best he can he's
full-time worker shows his wife right
dude
so what I'm saying is this I think it's
okay to have the dad bod if you are with
the kids at the pool you go by yourself
you better get in shape before you do -
don't be dad bottom with no [ __ ] kids
brah no not sad alright yeah a lot of
guys like oh I got a dad bod is like no
dude you're just out of shape you have
any children you know you just fat your
fat pot yeah you got that [ __ ] you don't
have kids you're just fat yeah or you
just have that gristle aeneas body type
you know good luck though brother the
struggle is real for us dads out there
yeah man so I say with the kids dad by
yes without the kids he's just fat yeah
you just got to tighten up a little bit
and do some a teaching dad bods if you
really have kids wear tight clothing or
do a onesie actually that's what I do
checkmate okay the last one this is
brace from Virginia Beach hell yeah I
love people that are named after things
that like are also like other things I
was so boys I got a quick King and your
sing it for you so my parents they have
a bad day and their bathroom and I'm
gonna be honest I've tried it out I've
tried it out party boy I want to know
y'all's opinions know your comedians I'm
sure you've been in some nicer hotels
and I mean you know some people think
it's a little homoerotic to be using a
bidet I like it ro you know you and your
brother used to play that game growing
up
or romper last episode just let me know
what you think but days king at her
stinging gang gay was boys
buzz-buzz young man listen I'm a bidet
fan have you ever sat down one of those
new toilets that are out there automatic
dude i sat down oh when I was in dr.
blood they can tell your blood pressure
they can do whatever you want get you a
grilled cheese whatever you want please
sit down and you can put the warm water
like you done taking a Dookie
it'll sprays that warm water all over
your junk from the balls to the the
booty hole and it is so refreshing and
nice it's a bidet it's a new-age bidet
now have I drank from a bidet cuz I
thought was a water fountain yeah half
it was in my uncle's house haha I did
that for many years in Venice California
oh that's why I'm such a large man a fan
of the New Age bidets if you've raised
all day water yeah my dad never told me
you're gonna put on some size dude okay
second of all first-team all the day
look man uh what was the guy asking us
bidet days yeah but days man hmm you
don't want to be walking around with him
dingleberry he's like all [ __ ] swamp
ass man that bidet cleans it right the
French had it right dude clean your
[ __ ]
I know some friends that clean that
[ __ ] in a sink usually can't afford a
bidet I don't think you need a I mean I
think if you're used to cleaning your
[ __ ] regularly like you know most
people are almost a hundred percent of
people probably a hundred percent of
people then I think you just do that but
if you're some [ __ ] psychopath who
has to have warm water shot at their
[ __ ] oh it's nice it's not you you
live have you ever had it done oh I've
been on one of these suckers before man
I don't like really it feels like an
invasion of privacy if I miss a little a
tool I get old turned on its hot water
it's almost like aliens coming
and have an erection bidets man I just
it just seemed like a Dark Arts to me
man the darkest yeah it seems like
that's clean airy it just I mean it's
God's work man
I would rather kind of hold like lift
one of my legs up and kind of hold my
ass open a little bit in the shower like
an adult it seems that's a bidet
different style though
yeah but stop and sit down below I'd
rather meet the devil halfway dude then
just sit right there on that fire hose
what do they say brother no this is for
you guys to say this is king of missing
Oh King it love them if they're done
right they're done right dude
it's not a [ __ ] carrot cake here's
the thing bro I've been on samba days
they get it gets messy that's what I
much pressure the feather the [ __ ]
strings a little too fat yeah it gets
water up there you know I'm feeling a
little too strong come a little too hot
oh yeah gotta be done right it's just so
risky when you could just clean your own
butt it's so risky I water shot at your
[ __ ] and an unknown [ __ ] speed or
pressure when you could just easily
clean your own butt like you've been
doing for decades yeah I'm with you man
I'm a fan of bidets is that it hot boys
guy that juvenile made my day dude I can
I appreciate that memory thing slow
motion for me
I won just drop oh my god bro yeah Brock
we're done Houston I come in September
20 21st after that end of September I'm
at Comedy Works in Denver get your
tickets t5k calm do and yep that's it
man I don't know what's going on with me
but you can check me out on this past
weekend um and what else about you boys
hopefully your boy won you feelin this
way before so bro we all looking for if
you want what's up broke his foot I'll
just get in dude yeah sure y'all brother
gang gang buzz buzz baby
[Music]